it's a scorcher lancelin likes it that
way off we go
lance lynn going to the mount for his
24th start of the year looking for his
11th win his era a fine 220.
145 strikeouts and 130 innings only 40
watts that's awfully good and as you can
see right-handers do nothing with them
to the tune of 180.
lynn is ready the 3-2
on the ground right-sided it gets under
the glove of hernandez base hit in half
[Applause]
and it's strike three
[Applause]
mills on the mound
five wins on the year that ties his
career high
first one to anderson
backhanded nicely wisdom strong throw in
time
jose gives it a ride right field side
and abraham rings it around and jose
abreu
is into second base he did not miss it
by much
on the ground that'll get through duffy
racing towards second he's not stopping
hayward is single they're at the corners
and nobody out
two and two
struck him out
fastball would have been a strike and
now
how about the double play after the
strikeout robinson torino's here he was
the d.h last night
it's bunted out in front of the plate
trying to score duffing and the throw
goes to first in time a run scores duffy
did not get a great jump coming down the
line at third lin didn't even look at
him and he picked up the bunt and threw
to first they get the out at first but
the cubs get a run
on a bunt by robinson torinos cubs lead
one to nothing
dowell swinging and missing and that's a
strikeout
the 2-2
goodwin swings and misses at a high
fastball
back-to-back strikeouts for alec mills
is the 2-2 on the way swing and a miss
mill strikes out the side
two and two on ortega
oh he struck him out
he's feeling pretty good about that
[ __ ] he got it inside that was a nice
[ __ ]
oh two struck him out downstairs on a
change up sebby the peg inning over
[Applause]
on the ground to third wisdom they get
it to second for one return to first two
he's ready here's now a one one
diving play wisdom gets up fires him out
at first at a heck of a play
by patrick wisdom stole extra bases from
anderson
what a great play by wisdom to end the
third inning and here he is leading off
the fourth
and there's power left field deep
jimenez back on its way gone he's done
it again patrick wisdom
it's two nothing man alive
and a good pitch to strike out on as
well two down
vega hitting 500 with the bases loaded
with a grand slam and 15 driven in in
his career lynn goes here
swing and a high fly ball right field
vaughn back here the whoa and it's gone
grand slam rafael ortega
an 0-2 pitch and he hammers it over the
right field fence
founding ball alcatra to second duffy to
first double play
here's wisdom now wisdom one out of two
a solo homer his 24th
here comes the 2-2
wisdom hits one in the air deep left
field going back jimenez he turns around
it's gone
patrick wisdom with his second home run
of the night cubs now up seven to
[Applause]
nothing and that one bounced softly over
the mound charging duffy collects tosses
to first
and gets born so on the play brondall
down to second but
the 100
in the year right field playable hayward
out number three and mills has fired
five shutout innings
[Applause]
2-2
and that's lined into right that's a
base hit first knock
for alcantara
as vaughan gets it back in
[Applause]
timothy short
runs it down uncourts a long throw and
got him
spectacular play from tim anderson
[Applause]
popped up a mile high oh my goodness
an eight pitch inning as wisdom pulls it
down
six shutout frames for alec mills it's
seven nothing
[Music]
2-2 swing and a miss on a curve in the
dirt zavala will fire to abreu that is
the first out
[Applause]
got him swinging curveball two down
curveball middle middle ruiz strikes out
the side well done stretch time at
guaranteed right field stocks have some
work to do
the 2-1
on the ground to third wisdom on a big
hop
[Applause]
that throws out abreu
[Applause]
softly on the ground alcantara
and two down
[Applause]
in the air out towards left center
ortega there he's got it seven shutout
innings
alec mills has been masterful here
tonight and the cubs lead at seven
nothing
cesar and tim got back got the turn
4-6-3 on a double play
in the year left field ortega back back
some more makes the catch that's a nice
play
that is a straight up doug lanville
ball wall ball
in the air out towards right center
hayward back slowing down and onto the
track he makes the grab
that's the third wisdom
takes his time throws out the catcher
it's eight shutout innings for alec
mills outstanding
[Applause]
a little roller to short alcatra picks
it up and throws out anderson
what a performance a great great
performance what a job here tonight alec
mills
eight and a third and he'll hand it over
to the pen
[Applause]
on the ground
and alcantara and that'll do it
alec mills a brilliant performance and
the cubs shut out the white sox seven
nothing
you